Oh Magnus is offline it's a ragequit no
I'll give her the moments that's so sad
is it really a rage quit oh he's back
he's playing karlovy he's playing atomic
chess what is this
what Magnus is playing atomic chess what
is this what he's playing a 1400 is he
insane he did this earlier to some
random person like why is he planning
atomic for those who don't know where
the atomic is just brace yourself like
we're about to see a massive explosion
on f2 what is atomic chess so atomic
chess is when whenever there's a capture
the pieces are round the capturing
square explode h3 is a good move so for
example if black plays Knight g4 and
white takes then everything explodes g4
g 3 and f3 all explode and everything
disappears and then Magnus just pre
moved Bishop g4 so slow motion replay
Knight g4 explosion Bishop g4 he wants
to take on a 2 and expose everything so
f3 what is this this is insane
this is really just insane why is he
playing atomic for a he's fighting
against a 1,400 this guy must be like
freaking out
like imagine Carlsen just starts a game
with you in atomic so the Queen's about
to come in like if the Queen comes in
it's just lights out for whites whoa
it's a dollar I don't know what that
says I missed it's well thanks for the
dollar I don't even know what the name
was f3f3f3 I appreciate the dollar if
anyone caught with that said and it was
appropriate let me know in the chat oh I
could go to Stream labs maybe I should
go to stream labs so this is still kind
of a fight but now Magnus wants to play
this and explode so a3 I'm gonna see
another explosion Magnus is up three
pawns
I mean White's putting up a fight like
you're playing the world champion and
atomic and you're not getting crushed
instantly it's not bad g5 is a good move
this bishop can move because the rook
will take on each seven you have to play
I have to move h-bond
maybe Bishop d3 I'm rooting for white
now I want to see you white when the a3
you can move oh this is over because b2
is about to explore then now Rock a1
okay get ready for it get ready rook
takes c2
and the king goes bye-bye ouch